someone say thrift store thrift
[Music]
store thank you for let me
be
again Jake the overwhelming time
pressure
yep I'll sign us up for the contest good
idea oh and Amy your dress makes you
look like a
mermaid okay I'll see you in a little
bit who wants some
alcohol all right boil Rosa and Amy
you're up come on get on it and under it
bang rang ases Nam ases you don't want
to be around H in your current state say
hello to the most confident woman
alive drink number
five you are a true friend and a hot
little
piece goodbye for drink Amy sloppy
sicko damn sir you took that Sharon to
the house how you feeling let me take
stock my equilibrium is a skew my vision
is partially impaired and I'm clearly
slurring my words to put a fine point on
it your boy's turned well well well
there's only a minute left and you are
six bucks down I don't think you guys
are going to make it hang another sharp
this one's hot it was sitting on the
radiator
he's never going to make it yes he will
just don't breathe let the liquid into
your
lungs 5 4 3 2 Closing Time
[Music]
cop all right fine the bar is yours
but we're keeping this come on before we
all go home and P ass out I want to say
how sorry I am that I deserted you
earlier I want you to know that I care
about you all so very much each and
every one of you boil Santiago Diaz
Hitchcock
SC whoa whoa whoa slow down sir you
didn't even stop and sniff the bouquet
you always sniff the bouquet maybe the
old H did but the new H chugs balet from
a burgundy glass without a
care oh it's a s turn glass
look the alcohol has rendered me a
simple Deion hey know I'm pretty good
right hell yes it's like a bunny rake
concert in here now hey we're about to
do the taser challenge you guys want in
what's the taser challenge we tase each
other then drink how do you win what are
you a lawyer you want in or not yeah
Terry what are you a lawyer it's taser
just get tased at a party man come on
this just just lifted Party
Time be
[Applause]
me
yeah are you supposed to be babysitting
Gina doesn't need my help she's over
there dazzling some psychologists all
men are at least 30% attracted to me my
mother cried the day I was born because
she knew she would never be better than
me at any given moment I'm thinking
about one thing Richard dfus hunkered
over eating dog food I feel like I'm the
Paris of people complet overlap of ego
and ID it's been theorized but I never
thought I'd see it I'm
Exquisite excuse me oh hey we were just
looking for a place to uh boink yep
boink that's my preferred term for it as
well I get it really engage kids enjoy
thanks
good good good good good kept our cover
intact nice work quick professional
thinking out there very quick very
professional detective detective let's
get back on the
case I can't believe I'm Frenching in
the closet I feel like a teenager my
feel like I'm 40
[Music]
again Nancy Myers never
fails now that we're doing it it feels
kind of weird to be staring at your
friends while they kiss are you kidding
it's
beautiful I must say this is quite
good is this sauce for your chicken at
my lamp H I don't know should we try it
let's risk it
go it's amazing I don't care for it but
I
tried and what a story for Kevin NYPD
we're Partners we' like to ask you some
questions you're not Richard Willcox
that's my grandpa he died a couple weeks
ago I'm just here cleaning out his shop
oh no something's wrong here oh you
think this Punk is lying partner no
something is wrong in my intestine due
to the street meat we must go now
okay oh okay all right I'll
drive sir we could find a public
bathroom no this is a very private
[Applause]
[Music]
emergency
hey Captain are you just waking up it's
11:00 a.m. no no I'm just tired cuz um I
worked out so much this morning you know
swapped 400 on the bench push Fitness
and whatnot what's up I need my laptop I
want to practice my speech with the new
colors beforehand so I'm not alarmed
when they pop up right right um I know
that Terry definitely did do that work
so I'll just go grab him uh you wait
here you can't come in
because Amy's naked and she's
embarrassed of her weird
body
[Music]
nobody can ever know that we had sex all
right I have spent years cultivating a
reputation as someone who sleeps with
bike
Messengers or better my grandpa was an
old school cop this was his hangover
cure raw egg yolks a you look like a
corpse we just pulled out of the river
wrong I look like a cool rock star who
ODed in his own pool big difference I
told you not to let Jimmy Brogan
distract you from your work so I assume
you're not too hung over to do said work
nope it's like I never even drank and
that's not a hangover cure what that
it's just some protein for my guns I
drink one every morning before I
lift
so
a so good you can barely even tell it's
a chicken embryo you should drink it all
for your
guns
[Music]
yeah just like Fitness right Rosa I need
you to work out with hope for the next
half hour
cool great I'll get your
sneakers this is invigorating isn't
it I am way too sleep deprived to deal
with your negativity right
now I am so hung
over did we steal these sunglasses last
night no you paid the bodega guy $200
for them and his shirt oh that explains
why I have a tri XL Scarface hoodie on
my
couch anyways I'm going to go crying the
bathroom peace out
homies